Harley Quinn's big screen debut in David
AA Suicide Squad was one of the movie's
biggest drawers especially since Margo
Robbie was playing the famed villain as
with any other comic book character a
lot of media attention focused on her
costume particularly how much of it was
missing when asked about her body
hugging costume Robbie told the New York
Times that Harley was quote wearing hot
pants because they're sparkly and fun
but the actress personally felt
self-conscious about the outfit Aya
defended The Look by saying that he
didn't think denim overalls would be
appropriate for that character because
that clearly was the only other possible
choice